welcome back
[Laughter]
all right huh
yeah
the atlantic insists you're scary if you
say the hail mary it's the left's latest
smear saying rosaries are something to
fear
a writer for the atlantic
actually compares the catholic rosary to
the ar-15
you know which might explain all the
drive-by praying that's plaguing our
major cities
i was just hit with a whatever
why am i chasing this joke quote
just as the ar-15 rifle has become a
sacred object for christian nationalists
in general the rosary has acquired a
militaristic meaning on this extremist
fringe rosary beads have been woven into
a conspiratorial politics and absolutist
gun culture
wow sounds like fun
daniel panton talks about a quote
catholic cyber militia who use rosary as
weapons memes not memes you say
oh i hate getting shot at with memes and
apparently there's a store that sells
replicas of combat rosaries used by
american troops during world war one
you know but maybe this writer's editor
could have informed this idiot that
their combat rosaries in the sense they
were for soldiers in combat
not for use in combat
i mean i guess you could you could poke
someone's eye out up close
but it would be easier to use your
finger
so now rosary beads used for centuries
in prayer are a symbol of far-right
violent extremism soon they'll be
comparing nuns to terrorist parents at
school board meetings
and what's next comparing holy water to
moonshine
mother mary to eva braun the crucifix to
the swastika
but we know rosaries don't make good
weapons otherwise biden would have left
billions of them in afghanistan
[Laughter]
as a devout atheist how does this make
you feel
no greg you know i i pray the rosary and
it is the whole
play you know what's not comforting he
prays the rosary when we're landing in a
plane
he was behind me you were behind me
during the rosary while we were landing
that's not comforting uh
did we land safely greg yes yes we did
yes but i do appreciate that
but yes it's always been a weapon the
rosary is a weapon we've always referred
to it that way it's it is a weapon of
prayer and when mary came down to those
children in uh in portugal as you know
greg she told those children to use the
rosary as a weapon to pray to end world
war one
and
christians catholics uh have always
weaponry is all through many different
prayers
you're probably in mass this sunday you
probably recited saint michael the
archangel defend us in battle because we
are protection against the wickedness
and snares of the devil there we go you
can we humbly pray i remember i was
catholic for a while
damn
[Applause]
you still are cat
still are no
mary tyler moore
song no i heard that for the first time
thank you you're welcome
so anyway this is weird this is like
that i called it the target expansion of
demonization or ted i coined this that
they try to make they try to uh amplify
the amount of evilness by all of these
like last week we did it about flags
right the um betsy ross flag was
considered terrorists now it's rosaries
isn't it amazing how they always say
ar-15 just so bad and we can't have
ar-15s even though we have the second
amendment but now they want to give
ar-15s to the irs yeah pretty crazy um
so the rosary is a weapon and uh when my
father was an inmate an incarcerated
person this is a true story they took
his uh his his rosary away because i'm
serious because apparently they didn't
want him killing again yeah but what he
said to me was if if they don't like my
rosary beads wait until they see my
rosary shank
because we all went to catholic school
as well and and that's anything's a
weapon if you're creative enough yeah so
was your dad in prison for murder
yes
i didn't know
should we go into this more no no no
there's murderers in the family he ain't
one of them
okay i'm serious
[Laughter]
you don't get this information on other
shows
all right andy you know what pisses me
off about this you know who does
rosaries little old ladies waiting for
the bus little old ladies on those my
mother did rosaries all the time this is
i find it so disgusting that this is
something that like people you're not
nobody gets hurt by your rosary but
somehow it's it's evil
some of my favorite parents do rosary
mm-hmm um
it's very it's offensive but you know
what worries me is how fast it changes
like remember the the kneel down
protests yeah in football when they
started
it seems like five minutes later
the pro everybody was protesting the
exception was the one who wouldn't kneel
right so we we poked fun at this but you
know rush limbaugh used to point out
that the stuff that we made fun of 20
years ago is now mandatory so it's it's
all well and good to to laugh it off
because
humor is a good tonic for that but
you know they're on offense yeah way to
bring us down andy
[Laughter]
last word you cat as an ex-nun
[Laughter]
i basically was yeah not by choice just
like my mom's rules yes
yeah you weren't even allowed to like
watch tv and stuff huh yeah like some i
could watch ewtn no i could watch some
stuff um i do know the rest of that
prayer and i will know it for the rest
of my life
uh you know and yeah it is a weapon
against satan right so if you're not the
devil then you've got nothing to worry
about yeah there you go well done
the devil's not watching though because
there's primaries tonight
that's true greg it's not just little
old ladies men pray the rosary ah yeah
look at you real man oh real man gotcha
okay
okay tom coming up should you take a
victory lap if your diet's crap
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else